[Music]
you cannot joke unless you're truly woke
on a recent episode of the joe rogan
experience guest dave chappelle and
rogan discuss the saturday night live
cast
and their whining over host elon musk
apparently snl cast members were furious
because musk was the only person on that
show that anyone has ever heard of
i've never heard of any of these these
so-called stars the snl cast has become
like a televised witness protection
program
no one is woke enough they they they
don't
they can't appreciate the fact that
you're dealing with literally one of the
most brilliant men that's ever lived
who's going to come do your show no one
can be woke enough you know
i'm torn because i like
a warrior for a good cause but i'm
really in
the tactics you're not gonna nag
people into behaving right in a way that
you know in fact if if you continue with
this tone
even if you're right you'll be very hard
to hear
his voice is oddly therapeutic now that
was recorded before musk hosted snl but
not only did he get decent reviews when
he did it turns out he killed
just like what he's planning to do to
those astronauts on their one-way
mission to mars
[Laughter]
musk gave him a huge ratings boost not
only in total viewers but in the key
middle-aged white guys who still live
with their mom's demo
good for them i say next they should
have new york governor
andrew cuomo host he can start the show
by saying
dead from new york it's 19 000 old
people
oh wow terrible
dad uh you've heard of snl right it's on
saturdays yes at night
yes uh do you think people were really
that upset about elon musk or was that
just a story
that i plucked from twitter and then
amplified it falsely
some people were actually mad which is
the craziest thing about it
and it is impossible to ever be
sufficiently woke because
uh it demand you know you can never have
ever
hurt the feelings of anyone even if
they're a stranger and even if you were
joking
so it demands perfection and humans are
imperfect so
never going to be possible exactly
exactly you know amanda my belief is
that the reason why elon musk was so
good on snl
is unlike most of those cast members
he's lived a life
it's like a lot of these young people
think they know actually they're just
like
they just read the same crap no i mean
it's the same thing we were talking
about earlier where he's a character
like he actually has a personality
they've gone to the point where i mean i
don't know how these entertainers are
going to entertain
when anything outside of like a blank
piece of paper is considered offensive
yes i mean it's just
they're going to run into that at some
point yeah and it is
it's it's almost like they're get wokism
is trying to get rid of the human being
that doesn't fit anywhere
it's the weirdest thing to me corey it
seems like the people that are truly
woke are like the cool kids
deciding that it's time to get rid of
everybody else well i really enjoyed his
opening monologue i thought it was funny
um and the italian in me appreciated the
wario skit
yeah that was so odd
it was good did you see that grimes was
made a little cameo in the show you okay
you know i moved past that i don't think
you have
let's not talk about her i'm sorry i
brought it up jimmy what are your
thoughts on every what are your thoughts
on comedy in general and how woke has
woke has infiltrated how it's affected
it i'll tell you why
real two things first of all uh the old
snl cast
is so devastated by the actions of this
cast they would never
shun someone who smokes as much weed as
elon musk
think about the amount of cocaine money
a guy worth 182 billion dollars could
have gave my man john belushi back in
the day
he would have been a hero but what
happened is woke-ism has forced comics
to take themselves too seriously
and every comic watching most of you
hate watching because we're on fox right
now yes
i need to understand we're liquor pimps
that's what we do for a living we get on
a stage in front of 300 strangers
and make them laugh so someone can sell
liquor that's the vast majority of our
job description is an hour of pimping
liquor
23 hours of watching dirty movies in the
la quinta and if you're lucky
if you're lucky if your career is going
good and you're getting laquinta which
is a nice hotel
i mean making your bones before i got
here to fox you know i'm playing in the
kind of hotels
where you can see the dimples in the
door from where the state troopers
battery rammed it down the night before
and and comics got to this place where
it's it's become more important to
to placate a community that doesn't care
about you anyway right
than to own your position as a comic
like our job as a comic is to point out
the truth
in everything in society it's not to
take a side because taking a side
will oftentimes deny you a basic truth
and you know what's happening to that
to comedians is that they are uh they're
not
embracing a topic that would be perfect
for them which is focusing
and they can't even do that no you can
make fun of it all day because this is
the show this whole show is predicated
on canceling
and wokism and it's like because no one
else would yes no that's the whole hook
and like people don't get it it's like
we're abandoning
and fighting this battle on grounds that
aren't favorable to us
our advantage is to point out the
ridiculousness when you have to defend
the ridiculousness you become
the joke yeah and that's the sad state
of comedy right now is there's no like
um
you know previous generation of comics
that really respects what's going on now
and even chappelle chappelle if you
watch him it's like if you've ever
watched the snake charmer try not to
come out of the vaz chappelle wants to
be a republican
he's trying to stay in that vaz so hard
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else